♪
Uh, Ilana, why is there no 2:10
train to Bridgeport anywhere?
I don't know--
I'm not a conductor.
Ilana, these are
Amtrak tickets, dude.
It only runs outta
Penn Station.
Oh, gross.
Alright, let's go,
come on.
I-I can't run.
I'm gonna sweat
off my concealer.
Holy (bleep)!
This place really
is majestic.
♪
(Morgan)
Taxi!
It's been a whirlwind,
right?
I know.
Both been
having fun.
Yeah.
Talked about
getting that dog.
Uh-huh.
But, um, Penn
Station-I can't.
It's disgusting.
It's kind of a
deal-breaker for me.
Okay, I'm confused.
Maybe this is one of those
romantic New York City stories
where you meet someone amazing,
and then... tragedy happens.
And they're gone, and
you never see them again,
and you wonder what they did
with their whole life.
Good luck, kid.
(Morgan)
Taxi's here.
Come on!
Okay, everybody in.
Abbi, sit by me.
(Abbi)
I don't even know
what just happened.
(Morgan)
Okay you sit in the middle, but
I don't wanna sit next to Ilana.
(Ilana)
Sure, sit on
Morgan's boner.
(Abbi)
Guys,
I just got dumped.
Abbi, wait!
Wait!
Oh, it's just
not meant to be.